convaincu d'avoir ou pas avancé non
seulement ici en stage on a un truc
auquel on monte avec away tu as aussi
les auteurs en sus les autres on suit
les autres que oui buffalo d'avoir
gonflé les dates là on va y aller fort
on peut tout arriver devant il s'en
servait bord ont pas trop quoi varier
raplapla plat tu vas rester au milieu
voilà tu vas en avoir plein autour d'un
arbre à la télé ou à aller au dessus
voilà voilà
ces jolis dessous des mois autour de
l'arbre c'est magnifique ça attention
votre vie par il porte un peu vers la
gauche
ok mais rechercher un sens très large
chez vous ça sent pas comme head of
lords of the water que les voix devant
auparavant juste devant le sénat qui
sont dans l'eau en contre jour qui
arrive c'est super beau tu les vois pas
les voix devant le voile sur d'or le
haut les cleantech
c'est donc vers ronds et bien d'autres
qui arrivent aussi paraît-il à droite à
droite de ce qu'ils voient arriver une
rencontre qui arrive dans l'eau je le
vois pas bien le seul hélicoptère me
gêne
il évoque aussi les voix à droite
regarde ses superbes aura pas ça tu les
vois ceux qui sont en haut dans l'eau à
droite oui vas-y toi de tes peurs voilà
il traverse les voies c'est super beau
ça voilà c'est super ça devant 12 6
grâce à nos radios ont pesé contre jour
sublime
c'est ça le gros troupeau là c'est super
beau parcours comme toujours c'est pas
pourquoi on line 65 réadapter au caire a
trouvé les autres du boulava là c'est
bon ils ont retrouvé sauvagement
prouvent les autres super très bien
qu'on permet d'alléger ses stocks et à
38,10 encore voilà rester et c'est comme
ça ils vont sortir du champ maintenant
en bouffer les scop ça reste comme ça va
sortir comme ça
c'est bien ça arrive de partout en
courant et la donne et il en a encore
d'autres qui arrivent c'est incroyable
et nous encore qui arrivèrent le
troupeau donc qui vont se retrouver
enfin si vous les voyez vaste encore un
autre on se moque arrêt pendant huit
chercheurs pour tous - michel est et est
le plus important
et sinon un pays au palais qu'on a un
plan foncier de le tir essayer de le
faire bon sens trop pour le troupeau
dans la poussière au cinéma avec les
arbres enfin nombre dans le passé c'est
bon c'est très bon que tara d'arbres
avec tous les peuples au tour tu vois
plus haut c'est bon tu vois cela témoin
ils vont tous passés de chaque côté de
la rue c'est super beau ça assez
positive et a couru autour de l'arbre
c'est vachement beau regarder
superposées puis vous reprendre le
chemin de polar comédie avec tous les
buffles
de poussière regarde la poussière c'est
magnifique pour bien les poussières un
peu à gauche la toile et 8 rebonds entre
beau l'arrivée à contres c'est bien
d'ailleurs sur le lac au bout du ponton
je veux jouer
il est amputé l'envi que ce quota paul
badama ok c'est bon ça c'est un contrat
doctoral ou encore qui arrive j'y crois
pas tant changé leur vie c'est bon c'est
bon
jolie en faveur du mois c'est qu'elles
sont loin qui arrive va pas discuter la
capitale hélicoptère 50 ces jolies dames
pourtant plus resserrée terre-océan très
doucement pas par la coopérative on a
l'impression que ce soit pour on la
regarde et le cercle là
par l'impression qu'ils ont peur de nous
un sage ne pas offenser virapatrin 6h un
paul quin hélas hélas il en faire
l'amère bien serré dedans on la bâche et
pousse et c'est en donnant un sérieux
atout vraiment content là bon sens bien
l'arbre tout à ce poste si alors tout
seul qui au milieu de la fumée autour
c'est vachement beau là c'est vous c'est
moi c'est superbe c'est en réalité un
blouson il voit pas où on est vachement
beau ça n'allait plus yahiaoui là
le pont pour vous obama ou pas bon on
fait de sorties ou à je sais pas trop
comment on peut sortir de ça mais risque
il est l'arbre il ya quelque chose de
merveilleux a regagné la poussière qui
est fabuleux et mes cordes par as tu pas
d'horizon que ça en fait si on va il n'y
a pas droit ne se passe rien la finance
est temps qu'il se passe rien là dedans
les en retard là du tout plein c'est
réussi de faire un plan serré c'est
alors